bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
retrouver sur public sénat pour suivre
en direct les questions cribles
thématiques sur le thème des services à
la personne les questions cribles
thématiques vous le savez c'est une
série de questions posées par les
sénateurs à un membre du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est laurence rossignol
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
et des personnes âgées qui vient leur
répondre quelques chiffres pour situer
ce secteur il pèse 20 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires et emploie
officiellement 2 millions de salariés en
france
les questions devraient porter sur la
fiscalité et le travail informel
en effet le taux de tva sur les services
à la personne a changé pas moins de
trois fois depuis 2012 de quoi rendre et
lisibles les tarifs pour le grand public
et de quoi favoriser le travail gris ou
le travail au noir
voilà les questions les thèmes ne
manquent pas sur ce sujet je vous laisse
tout de suite découvrir les questions
des sénateurs dans l'hémicycle
voilà vous voyez gérard larcher qui
s'apprête à ouvrir la séance de
questions cribles thématiques laurence
rossignol qui est assise au premier rang
on attend sans doute les derniers
sénateurs qui doivent s'asseoir dans
l'hémicycle pour poser leurs questions
je voulais dit sur le thème des services
à la personne
on a en tout cet interlocuteur qui vont
intervenir sur le thème des services à
la personne
une parité entre les groupes politiques
les questions cribles thématiques
devraient commencer d'un instant à
l'autre
gérard larcher président cette série de
questions il a d'ailleurs annoncé la
suppression des questions cribles
thématiques
un exercice qu'il avait les nerfs et
voilà petit la séance est reprise à
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
cribles thématiques qui s'occupe
d'ailleurs qui vont disparaître je
profite de la présence de roger
karoutchi et dallas richard pour vous
dire que ces séances seront remplacés
par les questions d'actualité en
fonction de la décision du bureau sur le
rapport de notre de nos deux collègues
du groupe de travail et ces questions
cribles thématiques aujourd'hui vont
être posées madame laurence rossignol
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
des personnes âgées et de l'autonomie
sur les services à la personne
cette séance est retransmise sur france
3 et public sénat
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean marie vanlerenberghe président du
groupe de l'union des démocrates et
indépendants union centriste vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue le président
je vous remercie de cette promotion mais
je ne suis pas président monsieur
monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
cette question précède de quelques jours
la discussion du projet de loi sur le
vieillissement dont la philosophie qui
l'inspiré de maintien des personnes
âgées à domicile
pour ma part j'ai présenté le 4 juin
dernier avec notre collègue dominique
watrin rapport sur le sujet et notre
constat pour ce qui concerne les publics
les plus fragiles
ces personnes donc les personnes âgées
handicap est alarmant le système est à
bout de souffle et à réformer d'urgence
en effet les services dell à domicile
sont confrontés depuis plusieurs années
à une dégradation de leurs
situation financière qui peut aller
jusqu'à menacer leur pérennité
notre rapport formule 13 propositions
taux de trois axes la discussion du
projet de loi permettra de développer
notre position je me limiterai
aujourd'hui à la question financière
permettre aux seniors de rester chez eux
le plus longtemps possible est une
aspiration largement répandu dans toutes
les catégories sociales
le maintien à domicile d'ailleurs
l'orientation pour u prioritaire de
votre projet de loi malheureusement le
doute est permis quant aux moyens d'y
parvenir
c'est pourtant la voie d'avenir l'aide à
domicile c'est environ 8500 structure sa
157 mille salariés et la direction de
l'animation de la recherche des études
et des statistiques la dares estime à
300 mille le nombre de créations
d'emplois d'ici 2020 dans ce service
dans ces secteurs de services à la
personne
alors les aides à domicile des personnes
fragiles souffre néanmoins d'un grave
problème c'est que la part de l'état n'a
cessé de baisser depuis l'origine de 50%
à la création de la pl à 28 % en 2014 et
les finances départementales vous le
savez sont exemple faut donc réformer
l'apa fixer un tarif national de
référence et augmenter ses fonds
d'intervention
alors madame la ministre que prévoyez
vous pour répondre à la situation
alarmante que je viens d'évoquer
la parole est maintenant madame laurence
rossignol secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie de la parole de la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vanlerenberghe la réforme de
l'apa à domicile est en effet un axe
central de l'as du projet de loi
d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement que vous connaissez bien
et que votre assemblée examinera la
semaine prochaine et grâce à l'examen du
sénat puis à la navette parlementaire ce
projet de loi sera adopté avant la fin
de l'année 2015 pour une application
pleine et entière au 1er janvier 2016 ce
projet doit être une véritable réforme
de justice sociale qui permet d'attaquer
les inégalités à la racine et qui se
concrétisera par des moyens
supplémentaires quotidien qui changeront
la vie de nos concitoyens
et en particulier puisque c'est le sujet
vous avez évoqué la réforme de l'apa à
domicile que contient ce projet de loi
permettra une meilleure couverture des
besoins couplée à une réduction
significative du reste à charge pour
illustrer mon propos
j'ajoute que je pourrais dire que pour
les personnes en gir 1 ou 2 c'est une
hurd a pas supplémentaire pour ceux qui
ont déjà atteint le plafond dead et pour
les personnes moindrement affectés et ce
sera une heure supplémentaire par
semaine tous les bénéficiaires de l'ass
pas pourront désormais bénéficier d'une
prise en charge totale de leur plan
daide sang reste à charge la réforme de
la pac c'est aussi la création de droits
nouveaux pour les aidants le droit au
répit nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler plus longuement la semaine
prochaine donc la réforme de l'apa s'est
aussi 25 millions d'euros par an pour
soutenir les conditions de travail des
salariés du secteur et j'ai anticipé
cette mesure dès 2015 l'ensemble de
cette réforme de la pac représente un
financement nouveau de plus de 450
millions d'euros soit une revalorisation
de l'apa à domicile de 13% en une seule
fois c'est une avancée inégalée et
totalement inédite
ces dépenses nouvelles seront
entièrement compensées auprès des
départements chef de file des politique
gérontologique
ainsi le taux de compensation par l'état
des dépensiers à l'apa après avoir
effectivement chuté de 12 points entre
2002 ils étaient 2 43%
il était tombée à 31% en 2012
pourcentage auquel il se maintient selon
les analyses conjointe de l'audace et de
l'adf et il remontera grâce à la loi à
36%
c'est à dire que nour et amélioreront
ainsi le taux de compensation à en
direction des départements
enfin je voudrais souligner la méthode
de financement de ces toits c'est
d'abord une ambition financière puisque
650 millions d'euros supplémentaires
seront consacrés au vieillissement un
instru pardon et 650 millions d'euros
consacrés au vieillissement selon une
méthode originale qui est que nous avons
déterminer le volume des dépenses en
fonction des recettes de la casa mais
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans une
prochaine question je n'en doute pas la
parole est à notre collègue jean marie
vanlerenberghe bon madame la ministre
j'écoute effectivement les chiffres que
vous nous avez apporté que nous
connaissions déjà kong vase ont étudié
effectivement là le projet de loi sur le
vieillissement
je pense néanmoins que il restera un
effort supplémentaire à faire suffit
d'écouter toutes les associations ou les
entreprises des aides à domicile pour
s'apercevoir que leur pérennité
aujourd'hui est menacée et que les
efforts que vous avez rappelé ne suffira
pas malheureusement compte tenu du
vieillissement de la population et d'une
demande qui va croissante
voilà madame la mise mais nous aurons
certainement l'occasion d'y revenir la
semaine prochaine bien
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue jean baptiste lemoyne pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole celle ci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
l'accompagnement tout au long des âges
de la vie est un sujet majeur comme cela
état évoqué précédemment
c'est vrai dès l'arrivée dans un foyer
d'un enfant ce qui nécessite la mise en
place d'une nouvelle organisation pour
concilier vie professionnelle vie
familiale c'est vrai également avec
l'allongement de la durée de la vie qui
nécessite à partir d'un certain âge le
recours à des aides pour accomplir des
tâches ménagères ou recevoir des soins à
domicile
plusieurs types d'intervenants se
mobilisent pour faire face et nous aider
à titre individuel ou collectif à
relever ces défis
je pense aux aidants aux proches qui de
façon bénévole avec coeur et générosité
se dévoue sans compter
je pense aux dirigeants et salariés des
associations d'aidé à domicile plus
largement du secteur privé non lucratif
qui rendent de précieux services en
particulier dans les zones rurales pour
que l'éloignement ne soit pas synonyme
d'isolement définitif pour des personnes
âgées
je puis en témoigner en constatant le
professionnalisme et la bonté déployés
par les unes à ise dmr dans l'yonne
notamment dans le canton de chéroy bien
sûr mais je pense que tous les collègues
dans leurs territoires respectifs
pourraient également faire le même
témoignage
je pense également à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui interviennent auprès de
particuliers employeurs et à quelques
jours de l'examen en séance publique de
ce projet de loi relatif à l'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement je
tenais madame la ministre a appelé votre
attention sur plusieurs problèmes qu'ils
appellent des décisions pour pérenniser
l'ensemble de ce précieux tissu
s'agissant de l'aide à domicile la
réduction drastique des financements par
les carsat et les caisses de retraite en
matière d'heures octroyé à boutiers des
abois ratio des aberrations je parle de
cas concrets une personne aveugle mais
qui conserve sa mobilité n'est pas
éligible pour recevoir un dossier ne
serait ce que pour que sa situation soit
examiné des réductions budgétaires qui
effectivement plongent dans le rouge
nombre d'associations s'agissant des
particuliers employeurs notre assemblée
a adopté dans le plfss 2015 une mesure
qui visait à augmenter l'allègement des
charges pour l'emploi d'un salarié à
domicile mais vous en avez réduit
considérablement la portée en ciblant le
dispositif beaucoup trop précisément
alors madame la ministre vous l'avez
compris les retours d'expérience du
terrain montrent qu'il faut ajuster un
certain nombre de dispositifs
je ne doute pas de votre engagement
personnel pour autant vous donnez vous
les moyens de pérenniser et développer
ses activités non délocalisables qui
répondent à de véritables besoins pour
vous répondre mais par an le tableau
dames laurence re si vous avez la parole
même la ministre monsieur le sénateur
lemoine merci de salut mon engagement
personnel et il est à la hauteur de
celui de l'ensemble du gouvernement
depuis mon arrivée il ya un an j'ai
effectivement constaté pris la mesure
des difficultés du secteur de l'aide à
domicile pour en prendre la mesure j'ai
à la fois circulé sur les terrains j'ai
rencontré les fédérations et j'ai pris
connaissance d excellents rapports de
vos collègues watrin et vanlerenberghe
sur les services d'aidé à domicile
mon action et consiste à scier de
structurer une offre d'accompagnement
qui soit solide innovantes et viable on
ne peut pas continuellement construire
un secteur sur la base d'un fonds
provisoire reconduit chaque année
c'est pour ça que si ce fonds a permis
de mobiliser 130 millions d'euros depuis
2012 pour soutenir 1400 service il nous
faut quand même penser à une réforme
plus structurelle organisationnelle
c'est ce que je fais en
mettant l'accent en mobilisant le
secteur sur la création des espaces had
l'espace à des temps la fusion entre les
siad services infirmiers et les saad
services d'aidé à domicile
la deuxième deuxième sujet c'est gelé
d'évoquer les uns instances et les 450
millions d'euros supplémentaires que
l'état va engager grâce à la réforme et
6 à 4 450 millions d'euros vont venir
dans le secteur de l'aide à domicile
abonder les budgets et donner une
bouffée d'oxygène supplémentaire dans le
dans le secteur ce que je voulais redire
c'est que des tas j'ai aussi obtenu une
augmentation salariale de 25 millions
d'euros pour les salariés de des led à
domicile avec un rattrapage au 1er
juillet 2014 d'un point pour des
salaires qui avaient été gelées depuis
de nombreuses années et c'est là aussi
encore une somme supérieure à mettre
dans le budget de l'aide à domicile
à court terme le chantier de la
refondation est lancée avec mes
collègues
et cette année le vote de la loi c'est
le vote de la mobilisation
et croyez moi nous ne lâchons rien sur
le soutien et l'aide à domicile qui est
comme vous l'avez justement évoqué la
condition du maintien à domicile de jean
baptiste lemoyne mon cher collègue
oui merci aux cours et dames la ministre
pour ces précisions alors voilà les
paroles sont là et la semaine et la
semaine prochaine nous espérons que les
actes seront là pour adopter un certain
nombre d'amendements que la commission
des affaires sociales a adopté notamment
pour continuer à aider les départements
qui eux sont au rendez vous de cet
accompagnement des personnes âgées
il faut avoir en tête que la paix a
effectivement à hauteur de 70 %
quasiment est réglée par les
départements et nous aurons l'occasion
d'examiner des amendements permettant
peut-être de réviser les fractions de la
scène est ça qui pourrait être affectée
aux départements
c'est vraiment crucial et puis vous
évoquez les revalorisations alors
effectivement mais encore faut-il qu'il
n'y ait pas un effet ciseau qui fasse
qu'avec les décisions prises par les
carsat il y ait moins d'heures donc
moins entre guillemets de chiffre
d'affaires par les associations alors
même que effectivement leurs frais
augmente donc là il ya là un danger
potentiel qui peut remettre en cause on
l'a vu dans certains territoires
certaines associations donc restons
vraiment mobilisés et au rendez-vous des
amendements la semaine prochaine merci
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue françoise laborde pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues dans son
acceptation la plus large les services à
la personne englobe une grande diversité
d'acteurs et de public
ce secteur en plein développement fait
face à plusieurs écueils et plusieurs
rapporteurs rapport parlementaire lui
ont été consacrés la semaine prochaine
nous aborderons ces thématiques lors de
l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement qui apporte des
améliorations notables
ma question portent plus spécifiquement
sur les services aux personnes atteintes
de handicap et aux personnes âgées pour
lesquelles l'aide à la personne permet
de continuer à vivre aussi longtemps que
possible chez elles
pourtant cette aide à domicile et de
l'avis de tous un système à bout de
souffle
la réforme à venir ne répond pas
totalement malgré la nouvelle
affectation de la contribution
additionnelle de solidarité pour
l'autonomie
à la question de sa soutenabilité
financière pour les départements alors
que leur dépenses sociales ont connu une
forte hausse ces dernières années comme
l'indiquent une ré étude récente de la
direction de la recherche des études de
l'évaluation et des statistiques
par ailleurs quelle est la position du
gouvernement sur la proposition de
passage de l'ensemble des services
auprès des personnes handicapées ou en
perte d'autonomie sous le régime unique
de l'autorisation telle que prévue par
un amendement adopté en commission des
affaires sociales enfin le 7 mars
dernier à l'occasion d'une quinzaine de
rassemblements sur l'ensemble du
territoire des réseaux d aides à
domicile ont demandé un nouveau fonds
d'urgence pour 2015 sachant que la
réforme devrait entrer en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2016 madame la ministre
quelle est la réponse du gouvernement à
cette demande précise je vous remercie
alors on aime la ministre pour répondre
à madame laborde vous avez la parole
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde
vous avez raison cette dualité des
régimes juridiques autorisation et
agrément qui est héritée de la loi de
2005 sur les services à la personne est
aujourd'hui en état de fait
comment vous dire si ça n'existait pas
je ne créerai pas voilà et peut-être il
eût mieux valu au moment où la loi
d'être sur les services à la personne
était votée qu on isole les services
auprès des personnes âgées ou des
personnes handicapées néanmoins la loi à
10 ans et se sont développés de nombreux
services celle existant et il nous faut
aujourd'hui gérer ceci avec
responsabilité qui la responsabilité
nous invitant à la fois rendre le
secteur plus lisible mais aussi à
sauvegarder l'emploi
ma préoccupation avec marisol touraine
et ségolène neuville c'est
l'accompagnement des personnes
fragilisées autour de trois enjeux clair
la structuration territoriale de l'offre
notamment dans les zones rurales et
isolées
la qualité de l'accompagnement donc la
professionnalisation et les conditions
de solvabilisation de la demande pour en
limiter le reste à charge
faut-il pour autant mettre fin à la
dualité agrément autorisation je pense
en effet que nous devons réfléchir à un
régime unifié et promouvoir une
contractualisation pluriannuelle
cette cible est d'ailleurs un point
commun des derniers rapports et de la
cour des comptes et des parlementaires
sur le sujet mais derrière le consensus
de la cible il y à la méthode et un
calendrier
je souhaite pour ma part construire un
projet responsable et à long terme
la commission a introduit un article 32
et j'ai d'ailleurs leur demande
d'audition indiqué que j'étais à
l'ecoute de des propositions du
parlement sur ce dossier complexe mais
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter la
semaine prochaine
la rédaction de votre commission la
commission des affaires sociales soulève
néanmoins des problèmes importants en
termes de rythme de rapidité et d'effets
sur le secteur il nous faut donc viser
la cible et préserver l'existant pour le
faire évoluer je vous remercie madame la
borne chers collègues
merci madame la ministre cette réponse
est très claire et bien sûr nous
connaissons le contexte budgétaire
contraint dans lequel interviendra cette
réforme
je souhaitais cependant donc vous
alerter sur le décalage entre les
objectifs assignés à cette politique
publique et les moyens qui lui sont
affectés mais bien sûr nous en
débattrons la semaine prochaine je
voulais vous dire aussi que la mise en
place de mutualisation et
d'expérimentation va dans le bon sens
mais nous serons particulièrement
vigilants quant à la revalorisation et
l'amélioration de l'apa et attentifs aux
mesures indispensables destiné à rendre
plus attractif le secteur de l'aide à
domicile je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean desessard
pour le groupe écologiste il avait la
parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président madame la ministre et chers
collègues le dispositif du chèque emploi
service remplaçant 2006 par le chèque
emploi service universel cesu a fêté ses
20 ans décembre dernier ce moyen de
paiement et de déclaration d'une
simplicité exemplaire a permis de
simplifier les modalités d'emploi
domicile et de faire reculer
considérablement la non déclaration des
employés sécurité simplicité
d'utilisation larges possibilités de
cofinancement et avantages fiscaux et
sociaux ont contribué au succès du
dispositif que ce soit dans sa forme
déclaratives 1,4 millions de
particuliers employeurs utilisent ou
préfinancer 806 millions de titres émis
en 2014 le cesu vient grandement
faciliter la vie des personnes qui ont
recours à des services
je le disais tout à l'heure un vire
qu'est 1,4 million sur les 3,7 millions
de particuliers employeurs que compte le
pays
il s'agit d'un secteur important de
notre économie puisque ses employeurs
versent 2,02 milliards d'euros 1,6
millions de salariés chaque année les
avantages du cesu pour l'employeur
doivent se retrouver côté salariés et
des avantages notables ont été réalisés
à ce titre ainsi un partenariat a été
instaurée entre les représentants de
l'emploi à domicile et pôle emploi en
2009 il reste du chemin à parcourir
pour la simplification ainsi en cas
d'arrêt maladie
les salariés doivent demander à tous les
employeurs et y en a plusieurs
de remplir un formulaire assez compliqué
s'il manque un seul de ces documents
l'indemnisation n'est pas versée prenons
cas-là jardinier qui travaille pour 8
employeurs différents
il est malade et on comprend très vite
que ça qu'on demande d'indemnisation
relève du parcours du combattant
puisqu'il doit les voir chaque salarié
pour leur faire remplir un papier assez
complexe remplir alors que ces documents
existent donc pas d'âme la ministe
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour que les employés rénumérés par le
cesu bénéficie d'une simplicité de
gestion en cas de maladie même la
ministre pour répondre à notre collègue
monsieur le sénateur jean désessard
seulement d'abord la simplicité du cesu
avant de que je vous suivre sur la
complexité de certaines situations mais
globalement nous avons avec le cesu un
dispositif qui est simple facile à
manier pour les employeurs en
particulier comme nous ne sommes jamais
en retard pour dénoncer les complexités
quand nous avons un dispositif réussi à
mettre en application ce salon le et le
cesu c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'il est
simple qu'il est utilisé chaque mois par
plus d'un million d'employeurs et un
demi million de salariés
c'est un dispositif qui est maintenant à
maturité qui couvre la quasi totalité de
la population des particuliers
employeurs qui sont éligibles et la
boîte finances 2014 a ouvert un à
l'outre-mer et de projet de loi la
semaine adaptation la cité
vieillissement prévoit la déclaration
des accueillants familiaux en ses yeux
vous soulignez cependant que certaines
démarches restent complexes dans la
mesure où le cesu ne les prend pas en
charge c'est et vous évoqué plus
particulièrement les arènes maladie la
réponse que je vous apporte consiste
d'abord à apporter une meilleure
information
grâce au portail unique unique ne tirais
particulier point fr par exemple les
particuliers employeurs à leurs salariés
disposent d'une information étendu sur
la protection sociale de base et
complémentaires ainsi que les démarches
à réaliser en cas de congé ou de fans la
relation de travail à la suggestion que
vous faites de permettre
une simplification des démarches liées
aux arrêts maladie pour les utilisateurs
du seuil eux et pour leurs salariés en
utilisant les données déjà disponibles
et les circuits suppose bien entendu une
analyse de faisabilité mais c'est une
piste de simplification qui paraît très
pertinentes au gouvernement et mon
collègue mandon toujours très attentif
aux propositions de simplification sera
très intéressé par d'autres propositions
et nous demanderons aux services de
champ de maladies et de l'urssaf de les
étudier
je faisais ça dans la minuscule bonheur
de vous avoir écouté un donc un vous
dites que le cesu effectivement à
simplifier madame la ministre a été
positive donc je la remercie a dit
d'abord que le cesu à simplifier la vie
effectivement et j'ai posé un problème
qui était celui de l'arrêt maladie ou le
la personne en arrêt m'a dit obligé
d'aller voir chaque employeur pour lui
faire remplir des papiers difficile à
remplir
et on madame la ministre a dit mais oui
ces documents existent ils sont cons ils
sont connus et il suffirait de demander
simplement aux payeurs que la paire est
validée que la personne est malade sans
remplir ses papiers complexe donc merci
madame la ministre de votre réponse et
merci des suites qui seront données par
le ministre que vous avez sollicité
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant notre collègue dominique
watrin pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue nombreuses ce
sont les fédérations dead à domicile qui
dénonce le décalage entre le coût de
revient de leurs prestations et les
tarifs horaires sur la base desquelles
elles sont rémunérées madame la ministre
cela fait presque un an qu avec le
sénateur jean marie vanlerenberghe
nous avons remis un rapport adopté à
l'unanimité par là commission des
affaires sociales vous alertant sur
cette situation
l'une des principales propositions
consiste à mettre en place un tarif
national de référence à la hauteur des
coûts de revient
où en est la réflexion de votre
ministère à ce sujet où en est l'étude
nationale des coûts
qui avait été diligentée par la
direction générale de la cohésion
sociale confirme-t-elle la nécessité
d'une tarification tour de 22 euros de
l'heure pour permettre l'équilibré
économique de ce secteur et assurer la
qualité des prestations offertes
quand deux tiers des départements sur
fond de désengagement de l'état pratique
des tarifs moyens inférieurs à 20 euros
de l'heure
les associations d'aidé à domicile
subissent aussi le contrecoup des
contraintes budgétaires des carsat qui
les amène à recentrer leurs
interventions des ménagères auprès de
public de plus en plus âgé 75 voire 80
ans contre 65 il y à 65 ans il ya
quelques années
que comptez vous faire pour mettre fin à
ce recul considérable en matière
d'accompagnement à domicile et de
prévention en totale contradiction avec
les objectifs affichés par la loi
d'adaptation au vieillissement
enfin dans ces associations il y à des
salariés 98 % de femmes rémunérées à 832
euros par mois en moyenne
les mesures de revalorisation d'un point
d'indicé attendu depuis 2009 ne sont
l'état qu'une aumône pour une profession
qui attend une vraie revalorisation
quels financements
comptez-vous donc mobilisés pour
répondre à tous ces défis est aussi mon
cher collègue pour vous répondre
la parole quand même laurence rossignol
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
il avait la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur dominique watrin les questions
de reconnaissance des coups de dés
services aide à domicile et d'émergence
internationales sont des questions assez
récurrente et j'ai bien en tête de votre
rapport co écrit avec votre collecte
vanlerenberghe sur le coût de revient
d'abord nous parlons d'une activité
économique qui est largement
solvabiliser par la puissance publique
comment dire je ne cesse d'entendre
parler de désengagement des tas de
21 milliards d'euros sont consacrés
chaque année en france à la prise en
charge la dépendance
donc ayant quand même toujours ce
chiffre en tête lorsque nous parlons de
ce sujet ce pur avant d'évoquer des
financements complémentaires il faut
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions de quoi parle-t-on de quel
panier de prestations dans quelle zone
d'intervention pour quelle qualification
des intervenants en résumé quel est le
service rendu aux personnes âgées
accompagnées à domicile pour répondre il
faut d'abord connaître j'ai fait
accélérer deux études qui sont très
attendus par le secteur l'évaluation par
l'igas des expérimentations tarifaire
sad qui est conduite actuellement dans
une quinzaine de départements et une
étude nationale des coûts et des
prestations dans 50 services qu'ils et
elles et réparties dans dix départements
ce rapport igas sera disponible avant
l'été et l'étude des coûts sera
disponible en certain septembre ils nous
permettront d'objectiver notamment les
différences de tarifs observables sur un
territoire et je m'engage monsieur le
sénateur et monsieur van den berg à vous
d'être ans à vous transmettre ces deux
études dès que je les aurais pour
d'ailleurs solliciter votre avis sur ces
études
deuxième question faut-il un tarif
national de référence a pas à ce stade
des travaux je n'y suis pas favorable
parce qu'il s'il était fixé il le serait
suffisamment bas pour permettre au
département d' ajuster en fonction des
spécificités
je souhaite pour ma part davantage
travailler autour de la généralisation
des contrats pluriannuels d'objectifs et
de moyens laisser pomme qui sont au
coeur de l'expérimentation conduite
entre l'adf et secteur ces pommes
permettre de financer d'une part les
prestations directes au domicile mais
aussi de prendre en compte les
spécificités des services dans les zones
rurales les horaires allergies les
démarches de qualité mais je crois que
nous aurons l'occasion là aussi de
continuer cette discussion la semaine
prochaine merci je dominique votre homme
sur collègues
oui madame la ministre vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma question sur le financement
et vous partez des contraintes financier
financière pour rejeter finalement
l'idée qui est largement partagée par
tous d'un tarif national de référence
des coûts à la hauteur des coûts de
revient
pour ma part m l'équilibré financier du
secteur je constate qu'à quelques jours
de son examen par notre haute assemblée
le projet de l'adaptation de la société
au vieillissement propose effectivement
quelques timides avancées pour les
usagers mais ces améliorations sont le
seul produit de la contribution des
retraités la casa taxe de 0 3% pesant
sur les sols retraités vous nous dites
que en fait vous pouvez pas répondre aux
défis faute de financement pourquoi ne
pas instaurer une contribution
solidarité des actionnaires qui
rapporterait autant que la casa
seulement 1% de taux sur les dividendes
des seuls groupes du cac 40 ou à 0 3%
comme les retraités sur l'ensemble des
200 milliards d'euros versés aux
actionnaires dans notre prix n'y at il
pas là une piste véritablement à étudier
si l'on veut véritablement répondre au
défi du vieillissement est mon cher
collègue
la parole est à peu près collègue jean
pierre godefroy pour le groupe
socialiste n'avait la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues le secteur des
emplois domicile représente 3,6 million
d'employeurs et 1,6 million de salariés
ce secteur continue à subir un fort
recul estimé à la perte de 35000
équivalent temps plein sur les années
2012 2013
les chiffres 2014 ne sont pas encore
disponibles mais on sait que la masse
salariale sera toujours en net recul
pour l'ensemble du secteur
lors de la discussion du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2015 un abattement forfaitaire
doublé avait introduit par un amendement
pour les particuliers qui ont pour une
personne à domicile pour des services ti
à la garde d'enfants aux personnes âgées
dépendantes et aux personnes handicapées
cette disposition a été censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel pour raisons de
forme
j'avais pour ma part déposé un
amendement tendant à porter de 75
centimes à un euro cinquante la
déduction forfaitaire par heure
travaillée pour l'ensemble des emplois
concernés indépendamment du nombre
d'emplois supprimés madame la mélisse
cette situation laisse supposer un
retour à une part de travail non déclaré
ce sont des emplois occupés souvent par
les personnes en situation précaire qui
voient leurs cotisations sociales et
retraites fortement diminué quand elles
n'ont pas complètement perdu leur emploi
se retrouvant aussi à l'assurance
chômage
nous savons d'expérience que les
variations des dispositifs
fiscaux et sociaux se répercute
directement et rapidement sur les
emplois à domicile et sur la façon dont
ils sont déclarés ou non
sans vouloir bien sûr revenir
intégralement sur les dispositions qui
existait auparavant par exemple
l'abattement de 15 points sur les
cotisations sociales des ménages qui
déclarent leur employé à domicile sur la
place du réel dispositif supprimé par le
gouvernement précédent
nous souhaiterions savoir madame la
ministre quelles mesures le gouvernement
envisage de prendre pour remédier à cet
état de fait préjudiciable tant pour les
personnes concernées employeurs salariés
que pour la situation de l'emploi dans
notre pays l équilibre les différents
organismes sociaux et pour vous répond
ma parole et a même laurence rossignol
vous avez la parole à mme la ministre
monsieur sénateur jean pierre godefroy
d'abord peut-être pour mettre tout le
monde à l'aise la baisse du nombre
d'heures déclarées n'a pas commencé
l'année dernière ni même ya deux ans
elle est engagée depuis 2009
donc chacun peut y prendre sa part de
responsabilité
et elle n'est pas corrélé ni avec un
essor des pratiques illégales ni avec
une quelconque évolution réglementaire
ou fiscales récentes mais comme l'a
souligné la cour des comptes en juillet
c'est principalement l'évolution à la
baisse du revenu disponible des ménages
et la maturité atteinte par le secteur
depuis la fin des années 2000 qui
explique les évolutions observées les
chiffres 2013 du secteur nous montre que
la baisse de 3 et 10 % des heures
rémunérées par rapport à 2012 est
uniquement imputable au recul de
l'emploi direccte l'activité des
services à domicile prestataires reste
quant à elle stable et l'emploi en mode
prestataire a même augmenté de 1 7%
on assiste en effet depuis 2002 un
mouvement de fond de bascule de l'emploi
direct vers le recours aux prestataires
ainsi les services prestataires sont
passées de 19 % du marché en 2002 à 41 %
en 2013
le conseil constitutionnel a sursis à
censurer comme vous l'évoquez la mesure
votée en juillet 2014 et le gouvernement
n'a pas souhaité revenir 4 cette mesure
présentait plusieurs limites n excluait
pas les services de confort et s'avère
ainsi mal ciblés elle aurait par
ailleurs étaient inopérantes pour les
publics fragiles les particuliers
employeurs en perte d'autonomie
bénéficie déjà d'une exonération totale
des cotisations patronales de sécurité
sial et sans plafond de rémunération
pour l'emploi d'une aide à domicile
quelle que soit la forme et la durée du
contrat de travail
enfin un mot sur la garde d'enfants le
gouvernement a fait le choix de cibler
son effort en apportant un soutien
financier pour les besoins de garde
d'enfants âgés de 6 à 13 ans révolus qui
ne brille aujourd'hui ne bénéficie
d'aucune aide aux autres que
l'abattement de 75 centimes et la
réduction d'impôt en doublant
l'abattement pour garde d'enfants âgés
de 6 à 13 ans le gouvernement a mis en
place une mesure de solidarité pour un
coût de 75 millions d'euros qui
s'inscrit dans l'ensemble des outils de
la politique familiale
merci sur godefroy moins chers collègues
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous remercie de votre
réponse ya des éléments qui sont
positifs dans cette réponse cependant je
crois que ne pas tenir compte du fait
que des dispositions fiscales qui ont
été modifiés et eu un impact sur le
volume d'emploi serait une erreur
il suffit d'ailleurs de se renseigner
auprès d'eux les personnes qui ont pas
des personnes aidées à laurier à
domicile pour s'apercevoir que ces
mesures fiscales ont eu un impact direct
sur les conditions d'emploi et sur les
heurts notamment en d'emplois je crois
vraiment que il faudrait réfléchir à
cette situation
on avait dit à l'époque était une niche
fiscale mais quand une niche fiscale
permet d'employer des gens qui cotisent
à la sécurité sociale aux caisses de
retraite je pense que ça mérite une
réflexion donc j'engage de gouvernement
on n'a pas le droit de faire 2 2 comment
dirais-je gouvernement mais j'en gagne
le gouvernement à réfléchir lors du
prochain projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale à la nécessité de
revoir quand même les dispositions
fiscales concernant les envois à
domicile collègues
applaudissements sur tous les bancs est
la parole à notre collègue cyril pelles
va pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les services d'aidé
à la personne permettent à travers la
diversité de leurs activités
une réponse globale aux besoins des
personnes âgées handicapées ou malades à
leur domicile
ces services sont indissociables des
politiques sociales menées par l'état
depuis les années 50
ce secteur est un vivier important
d'emplois pour notre pays avec le plan
borloo en 2005
le secteur a connu une accélération
importante sur la période 2003 2009 avec
la création de plus de 180 mille postes
mais malheureusement que constatons
depuis 2008 2009 une fragilisation du
secteur
l'aide à domicile est en effet
étroitement conditionnée au financement
public qui soutiennent le financement de
ses services et la fragilisation des
organismes d aide à domicile s'est
accentuée dernièrement on assiste en
effet à une baisse significative des
capacités financières de ses principaux
contributeurs caisses de retraite
sécurité sociale mutuelles et notamment
conseils généraux ces derniers ont su
combler les déficits
mais ces solutions restent ponctuelles
et locales d'autant que les dotations de
l'état sont fortement en baisse
les services à domicile ou à leur
trésorerie diminué de nombreuses
associations ont d'ailleurs mis la clé
sous la porte et on estime à plus de 300
les structures qui serait menacée face à
des difficultés économiques de plus en
plus croissante les organismes publics
et privés à but non lucratif demande une
réflexion sur le système de financement
des services d'aidé à domicile 1 déjà
éprouvée par la suppression
d'exonérations successives les
organismes prestataires ou mandataires
de mon notamment que la contribution
additionnelle de solidarité pour
l'autonomie mise en place depuis 2013
soit effective et que des 650 millions
d'euros prélevé cette année sur les
retraites imposables soit enfin alloués
à l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
madame la ministre il est du devoir de
la nation de prendre en charge la
dépendance et son accompagnement
soutenir l'aide à domicile c'est le
maintien de la solidarité en milieu
rural dans des zones déjà fortement
impacté par chômage la désertification
des services
c'est la garantie du maintien de
l'autonomie à domicile alors que les
structures adaptées pour personnes
dépendantes manque de lits c'est assurer
le bien-être des professionnels qui
exercent un métier difficile en évitant
le morcellement du travail conséquence
des économique de faire les organismes
c'est garantir un vivier dans point
important les projections sectorielles
pourrait être de près de 100000
équivalents temps plein en cinq ans est
d'environ 200 à 240 milles temps plein
dans les 20 prochaines années
madame la ministre il est temps de
penser à réformer le système de
financement la tarification de l'aide à
domicile
aussi madame la ministre je vous demande
quelles mesures d'urgence et quels
moyens financiers entend prendre le
gouvernement pour cette question
relevant de la cohésion sociale
je vous remercie de votre attention mais
si pour répondre cyrille pelegrin la
parole et à madame laurence rossignol la
parole madame la ministre monsieur le
sénateur bel va comme votre question et
convergente avec celles posées un peu
plus tôt par votre collègue jean
baptiste lemoyne
je vais d'abord redire je n'avais pas eu
le temps de dire tout à l'heure
concernant les le ce que vous évoquez
à propos d'une rétractation de la cnav
sur des carsat sur l'aide à domicile est
en fait ce qui est c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est que la cnav à reconcentrer
ces aides sur une logique de panier de
services différentes et surtout c'est
qu'elle a augmenté ses tarifs en même
temps puisque les tarifs de la cnav ont
augmenté de 3 6% avec un taux horaire à
26 euros
donc c'est pas un désengagement c'est
une réorientation et une reconcentration
de des priorités de la cnav un coureur
répondre plus précisément je partage les
constamment les partagent tous et nous
cherchons effectivement les solutions
d'évolution de la tarification
c'est pour ça que le chantier que j'ai
lancé cette année a depuis 17 décembre
avec l'adf nous avons élaboré la feuille
de route des réformes à conduire en 2015
je l'évoqué un instant là j'attends avec
impatience le rapport de l'igas sur
l'évaluation des expérimentations
tarifaire pour en tirer toutes les
conséquences enfin je j'ai lancé depuis
le 19 février la rédaction du cahier des
charges des spasad intégré de laquelle
j'attends beaucoup je ne fais tiji spa
l'espagne des spas sade mais je suis
convaincu que l'esp assad sont à la fois
une réforme de l'organisation du travail
une réforme de la qualité de l'offre et
de l'intervention auprès des personnes
âgées et une réforme de la qualité de
l'emploi et de la professionnalisation
des personnels qui travaillent et on ne
peut plus simplement remettre de
l'argent dans ce secteur sans faire
évoluer les conditions de tarification
et même sa structure et c'est pour ça
que intégrer
aide à domicile et soins infirmiers à
domicile et très probablement du moins
c'est ma conviction
l'avenir de ce secteur merci madame la
ministre je vais suspendre la séance
mais auparavant j'aurais envoyé mes
collègues
ovo ce qu'elle voit excusez moi une
mesure anti jeunisme ma part au
contraire c'est la gloire la jeunesse
comme je pense que mon collègue avait
déjà eu des réponses donc madame madame
la ministre vous remercie pour vos
réponses je suis forcément un peu déçu
je pense que les attentes dans ce
secteur sont très fortes et nous avons
besoin malheureusement de moyens pour
pour avancer voilà je vous remercie
merci monsieur p leva et pardonnez moi
j'aurais simplement renvoyé mes
collègues à la suite de la question
monsieur desessard au journal officiel
de la république de la séance du 10
novembre 1993 ayant créé le chèque
emploi service je suis heureuse madame
la ministre de voir que l'unanimité
s'est faite quand on regarde le débat on
voit qu'une bonne idée met du temps à
cheminer et la lecture de ces débats
vous montrera que en matière sociale on
peut faire des progrès y compris quand
on se situe dans une formation
comparable à la majorité sénatoriale
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'ai été
recherchée parce que j'avais quelques
souvenirs de l'époque
merci elle sera reprise notre séance à
16 heures pour la suite de l'examen de
la proposition de loi tendant à
interdire la prescription acquisitive
des immeubles du domaine privé voilà
pour cette séance de questions cribles
thématiques pendant 45 minutes vous avez
pu entendre la secrétaire d'état
laurence rossignol répondre aux
sénateurs alors certains se sont
inquiétés comme le centriste jean marie
vanlerenberghe et bien de la gestion des
services à la personne face au
vieillissement de la population comment
permettre aux personnes âgées aux
personnes handicapées et bien de
recevoir des aides à domicile laurence
rossignol a répondu qu'elle avait obtenu
une enveloppe de 25 millions d'euros par
an pour soutenir les salariés de ce
secteur et pour améliorer l'offre
notamment en zone rurale et isolée
d'autres réponses interviendront dans
les semaines à venir puisque le sénat
s'apprête à examiner en séance un projet
de loi relatif à l'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement de la
population
autre inquiétude elle vient cette
fois-ci du socialiste
jean pierre godefroy il s'est inquiété
du travail non-déclaré liées aux
changements de fiscalité dans les
services à la personne
un argument balayé par la secrétaire
d'état qui refuse de voir une
corrélation entre les changements de
fiscalité et la baisse du nombre
d'heures déclarées
voilà ce qu'il fallait retenir de ces
questions cribles thématiques très bonne
journée à vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires